[Music]
nothing turns this couples crank more
than singing Michael row the boat ashore
the killers started the search for
people to murder well before this couple
decided to start making out in the Attic
of this barn remember we saw creepy
stalking while this couple sang a Negro
spiritual to get in the mood
so was the killer walking around
expecting to find a couple making out or
did the killer look out at the last
second these horny teens know who this
is but they won't give us any clues
because they somehow know this needs to
be a surprise at the end of the movie
death by pausing whoa didn't even see
that class their cars a cab odd aint
Jeff what did this crazy local guy do in
the 22 years that Camp Crystal Lake was
closed down was he warning people about
the danger of CFCs it seems to be his
only function in life I'm concerned
about what he did in the ears where
absolutely no one was going to the camp
for any reason whatsoever
5 to 1 this guy rides a bike I can
already see it yep
crazy bike riding asshole local truck
driver plays the pronoun game so that
Annie has to ask who the hell he means
let me get this straight she's gonna
work at this camp for the summer and
absolutely no one offered to give her a
ride not even the other people she's
going to work with she couldn't even get
one guy with a crush on her to drive her
out to the site geez you think come on
dude
a minute ago you were like super eager
to help her out you got super angry
about crazy realm and now you warned her
about the police when you're halfway
there you couldn't tell her this before
she got in the truck with you two
murders in a drowning over 20 years ago
constitute a death curse one of the
dumbass kids in this truck is reading
The Godfather I don't think so it's not
like the book is high literature or
anything but no they're not reading that
book also discount Kevin Bacon wait
you're saying that is Kevin Bacon
okay so discount Kevin Bacon got him
while he was super cheap good for them
this fucking guy well at least he's
obvious about his creepiness what a dick
I mean who does this movie cast more
suspicions
Steve with the exact same Jeep that he
drove to lunch a minute ago but since we
later find out that Steve isn't the
killer how did the killer get the exact
same Jeep same paint job and same
hubcaps and why hitchhiking is just like
calling a cab no need for formalities
also Annie should immediately think it's
odd that the supposedly helpful driver
who is sympathetic to hitchhikers
doesn't say anything the entire time and
is totally down with taking her to Camp
Crystal Lake when all she's heard her
warnings and death curses about the
police and she came to town
SCOR throughout the movie is either an
homage to psycho and jaws or outright
theft if you send movies for a living
Annie will now do the trip and fall
while being chased through the woods
cliche 63 times during this chase
through the woods
what weird how her neck changed colors
before was sliced weird also moody kills
one of the cutest women in this movie 23
minutes in she didn't even get a chance
to do a horror movie nude scene
you can manatee bulges this is a great
trick to play when you're a straight guy
and you have a 50/50 chance of it being
a woman giving you CPR and all right get
that hair fixed the 80s Kevin Bacon is
addicted the other people who won't be
movie stars after this that's racist I
told you to sit on a Tonto that's racist
never keep the chief wait goodbye cop
character we'll never see you again
thanks for the out of nowhere warning
about crazy old ruff ruff just happens
to appear right after the cop warned the
cave counselors about him also I guess
he's now upgraded his craziness to
hiding in rarely-used rooms to spread
the gospel about the curse of Camp
Crystal Lake good God upset even a lake
when they were all swimming and you
would have had a more captive audience
it's downright bizarre that Crystal Lake
has become so cagey over an accidental
drowning in the murder of a horny couple
of teens over 20 years ago if there had
been a little bit more of a sample size
maybe I'd be on board but three deaths
Lily lingers on this shot long enough to
pad its 90 minute runtime couple stuff I
wish I had that cliche huh
Betsy Palmer first if this had been Jack
telling Marcy the stream there's no way
she'd sleep with it but since it's the
other way around Jack's willing to
accept anything as long as it gets in
late hey hey I sure can't wait to hear
Danny and the juniors tonight hit the
sack out why would you assume that they
didn't get to shelter in time is it so
bill could say nah I think they are yeah
I mean wink-wink nudge-nudge right sex
we've zeroed in on the camp's guitar
douche bag I really don't feel too bad
that he's doomed doomed play strip
somehow the TNA this idea suggests
especially in a horror movie from 1980
never arrives how did they miss Ned's
body on top of this bunk I know you're
horny and everything but damn that's a
huge oversight Kevin Bacon's right hand
holy Sh the killer was under the bunk
the whole time also killer waits until
Jack notices the blood to finally kill
him which there was no way to know from
under the bunk also how did the killer
get an arrow through the mattress and
perfectly into Jack's throat and with
the other arm holding his head down this
killer is flexible 40 yards to the
outhouse that's actually pretty good
which is why you're about to get an axe
to your head her first instinct is to
scream and not defend herself in any way
including but not limited to running
also movie kills one of the cutest women
in the movie 47 minutes in if they're
playing strip monopoly why did they even
bother laying up the money around the
board
stupid door that has nothing to do with
the killer interrupts wholesome game of
Monopoly all we have to do is close the
windows in your cabin that takes like a
few minutes why does this end the game
oh my god don't stop playing this game
also even though the game has ended
Brenda decides not to put her other
clothes back on and what we've been told
is not only a rainy night but a cold
night Steve's marathon lunch break
boldly marches into its seventh
uninterrupted hour no wonder reopening
camp Crystal Lake has taken more than a
year six new counselors up at camp
ever since I don't discriminate I'm
gonna creepily touch Kevin Bacon's hair
next week during campfire stories also
six you're expecting that hitchhiker
Annie to show up to right did you ever
wonder about her don't you think you
might have wanted to arrange a ride for
her out to the camp no need to kill the
vulnerable camp counselor who's brushing
her teeth right now
hiding and waiting is my game when did
this dude start having car trouble also
car won't start during a horror movie
cliche killer needs to pull an elaborate
trick to get Brenda outside when there
was a perfect opportunity to kill her in
the bathroom where did your rain slicker
go you're walking out into this mess in
that all the better to see you with my
dear I guess I mean this killer sure
makes a production out of killing I
guess her death was considered too
graphic to show on screen after we saw a
throat slit a throat arrowed and a face
axed also movie kills one of the cutest
women in the movie 57 minutes in how
could you not hear that fucking scream
no why would the axe be tucked into bed
isn't that a useful weapon the killer
might want to hide or keep for future
killings keep away from people who might
want to use it to defend themselves
later I don't know babe it's either an
elaborate prank from someone who is
extremely patient or there are people
getting killed at this camp right now
you heard the screaming no take your
pick
[Music]
I mean the guy only takes 10 hours to
eat lunch so he should be back any time
now you're all wrong without your way
today the wife is a nervous wreck till
we got him home that dude is married
that's all I need crazy Ralph's running
around I mean that guy doesn't even know
how to stroke women's hair properly mega
wreck happens just as the cop is about
to show up at Camp Crystal Lake and find
out something bad is happening there
killer just happens to be waiting for
Steve at the camp entrance those of you
hoping for an insanely high sin count
for this movie are gonna need to know
that for long stretches of time stuff
like the entire process of making coffee
is shown in real time this whole scene
is two minutes nothing happens
although the effectiveness is that you
think something might happen anyway
coffee is made here skip so his throat
was cut and then the killer took archery
lessons on his body out in the open I
guess really would like to see this
movie from the antagonist perspective
also is this movie saying that he's
pinned to the door by the arrows because
what a bunch of bull that is cartoon
barricade just dealing with death scene
less a good 40 seconds it takes that
long for her to run or do
anything other than choked down screams
here's the real killer driving up in a
jeep 40 seconds after throwing a body
out the window I guess for scare tactics
well I have mrs. Voorhees an old friend
of the Christie's why did you reveal
yourself to the last victim of the movie
why are you putting on an act now why
are you not knifing Alice to death
that's what killers say Alice run did
you know that a young boy drowned the
year before those two others were killed
his name was Jason did all of your
victims hear about your kid before you
killed them or did they all kill
themselves Jason was my son and today is
his birthday well isn't that convenient
and on Friday the 13th during a full
moon of all times
well I'll be there where's mr. Christie
I couldn't let them open this place
again good why didn't you just kill
Steve during the entire year he's been
fixing up the place I would have saved
you a lot of time and bodies watch you
did too strong and cunning killer
suddenly becomes not so cunning and weak
when it comes to this easy to kill last
victim mrs. Voorhees dragged a knee all
the way back to the Jeep after slitting
her throat what the hell for did she
know that someone would try and make an
escape in her Jeep just so they'd see
her dead body well these dead bodies
keep popping up out of nowhere at
perfect times don't think mommy did
you're dead kid also tell you to air out
all that exposition from earlier to mrs.
Voorhees will now use the tried-and-true
method of slapping someone to death also
where did her machete go
okay tie her up now maybe or something
else that might incapacitate her if she
happens to wake up
I'm not surprised mrs. Voorhees is alive
but how did she know to come out here
also once again she decides to wait too
long to kill Alice even though she had
the element of surprise death by slow
motion alright now that I've chopped
mrs. Voorhees head off time to get into
a boat and row across a dark lake Oh
like if she gave up why did she get in
that damn boat the first place because
so we can see the fake ending where
Jason comes out of the water for one
last scare now you know why this dude
wears a hockey mask I just want to know
how he grows to Kane Hodder size in
later chapters ma'am we didn't find any
boy and I'm going to imagine all the
sequels that entails during this
cross-dissolve
did you count 10 more plus a reboot I
counted 10 more plus a reboot
[Music]
there is only one river there is only
one sea Johnny
I'm serious honey your coffee's done
drinkable pretty harsh well so sure
coffee you know the girls down at the
office make better coffee on their hot
plates well see you later
thank you
very considerate
[Music]
[Applause]
boys are not know every second